welcome to scitrek your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
so anytime we get new star trek it's a
thing to celebrate right
so let's have a look at what we know and
what we can expect from strange new
worlds
[Music]
so we've already met some of the
characters from strange new worlds
captain pike was obviously a board
discovery for virtually entire series
and we got to know spock really well as
well
we saw the very hot number one which
we're going to see a lot more of and i'm
very excited about it but actually this
series has now been announced we have a
few new characters to get very
interested by we'll talk about that a
little bit later but what else do we
know about this series well one thing we
do know is the enterprise has got big
again
and the original series the enterprise
was around 940 feet long
this enterprise is over 1400 feet long
why did they do that jj abrams did it in
the movies he made that thing
massive
they haven't quite gone that far in this
series but what they have realized was
that this ship the original enterprise
needed to compare to discovery they'd
already built discovery and we kind of
had an idea how big she was so when they
realized they were going to bring the
enterprise in they realized it was going
to look very very small next to it
nearly a third its size
so they had to upscale the enterprise
and that's never a bad thing it's made
it a little bit bigger i'm not a purist
when it comes to canon a lot of the time
as long as they don't message history
too much which we'll talk about a little
later in the video
but
you know they've upgraded this ship i
think they needed to so they've changed
25 of the design of the enterprise the
actual shape and the um some of the
design features
a lot of people have said that's because
cbs don't really own the rights to star
treks they've had to change it for
within a copyright reasons it's not why
they've done it but could you generally
imagine an exact replica of the original
series enterprise in a modern
series tv series it would look
ridiculous
so yes they've modernized the design
using brand new special effects they
will be able to do so much more with the
enterprise and we get to see a lot more
detail
it was also though designed supposedly
to be an enterprise that could evolve
a ship that's not quite as advanced as
the vessel kirk will eventually captain
it's also not supposed to look quite as
advanced the discovery that supposedly
at the time was the most advanced ship
in the fleet
but i also love how they've done the
interior they've took a lot of the
design features from the original bridge
they've just made it bigger
you know they took the the red or orange
god that was a big argument the turbo
lift doors are still in the same
position that banister that surrounds
the captain's chair you know the
captain's chair is very very similar to
the original series so they've took
little design elements
and they've just modernized it for a
modern audience and modern special
effects and i think that was really
important to do and from what we've seen
so far they've done a beautiful job
i also love how they made the view
scream out of transparent aluminium
instead of sorry aluminum um instead of
just a like a tv screen or just a window
in the original series it's kind of a
window that they project stuff onto and
they couldn't have that as a stupid
modern design idea but but transparent
aluminium a little nod to the voyage
home there so what do we know about the
characters
obviously yep anson mount has come back
as captain pike ethan peck is back as
spock and rebecca ramich is back as
number one oh my god she's hot um but
she's back as the number one
we actually have a couple of new
characters though as well it has been
announced that celia rose gooding is
going to play cadet ahora
i love that and i'd love to see i'm
really interested to find out what
they're going to do with this character
but the character i'm most interested in
the one that's got a little bit of
mystery too
is the khan character
now we're not going to see car noonion
sink in the series but are we seeing an
ancestor
christina chong is going to be playing
lahan noonian singh
now there is no way in hell
that that is a coincidence and obviously
the internet is ablaze with theories
but let's break it down a little bit
from what we know about khan and what we
know about the storyline and
particularly where this series fits in
compared to the original series
so car noonion singh
was the leader of this superman
rebellion these genetically engineered
humans that were cleverer smarter and
very very aggressive they triggered the
eugenics war between 1992 and 1996 at
one point khan controlled the population
of like a quarter of the earth he had an
empire that was as vast as the british
empire was but humanity fought back and
they were eventually defeated
khan took the survivors the his supermen
and women and got aboard the botany bay
and cryogenically went into a deep sleep
only to then be found by kirk ten years
after the strange new world series is
set we also know that much of the
records from the eugenics war were
destroyed
either at this point either at the end
of the eugenics war or because of world
war iii that happened a few decades
later
so there aren't many records from this
time
when the original series crew find khan
they don't know who he is they don't
know what he is
now is that going to be important to
strange new worlds could this
sing character actually be an open
genetic augment
or is she hiding but she can keep her
name because nobody knows what or who
she is
in the enterprise series towards the end
of series 4 we have the double episode
where we saw anak sung
he had found some of the augmented
frozen embryos and he thought if he
raised them
properly
with correct teaching he could maybe
teach out some of those aggressive
tendencies
he failed it turned into a massive
battle
but the one thing that's always
interested me is
we don't know who created the original
augments
we do know that khan killed the
scientists supposedly but we don't know
who that scientist was we also don't
know how eric sung then found those
embryos
perhaps
this was another sung character perhaps
eric's father who was actually the
original engineer
is this something we could find out
about more in strange new worlds why
might we actually find out a little bit
more about the eugenics war and how this
all ties in together
the song character obviously
is one that reappears repeatedly
throughout star trek
we've seen atango sung in the last
picard series
creating an android nation on a distant
planet and obviously afton rongsung who
created data and b4 and law and was
really the father of android technology
could there be another song
about to appear in strange new worlds is
brent spiner gonna get another channel
chords have not happened yet
so we're way off that so we are in a
sort of cold war on and off aggression
with the klingons
the romulan conflict has happened
something i would have loved just in
enterprise but we never got to see
um
could they maybe change canon and could
be that something we get to see in
strange new worlds i doubt it
the the showrunners have basically said
that this is going to move back towards
more of an episodic series more like
classic star trek and away from what
we've seen in picard and discovery where
it's that overarching single story
through a series
we're going to get back to more like the
original series of star trek or the next
generation that's something i'm really
excited to see so i don't think we're
going to see any sort of big wars or
conflicts in the series
and anyways like say the time frame is
wrong for the romulan conflict anyway
but in this time frame very little is
known about the romulans
we know that from the original series
and even the beginnings of tng
that the romulans were not well known by
the federation that they were very
secretive and even when we did have a
conflict with them it was done at
distance we didn't fight them sort of
hand to hand it was not an aggressive
all-out war like it was with the
klingons so that is something that
potentially this series could explore
something that really disappointed me
about the enterprise series was we never
really got to see the birth of the
federation
this is 10 years before the original
series the federation is well
established but it is a little bit
younger we know from sort of the j.j
abrams movies that that when pike was
kept in the enterprise it was sort of
like the beginnings of the federation
could they sort of write that more into
the stranger world series and sort of
fix some of the mistakes that i feel
enterprise made but that's where i come
to my concerns about this series
i don't like pre-course i've said it in
many episodes before i don't like
prequels i think they risk messing with
canon
we know the star trek history it's we
have loads of books we have loads of
things we have loads of information
about the star trek history
and
that can be a good thing because it
gives us some continuity and it gives
them the show writers something to work
off but when they want to do something
new they want to do something
interesting it limits them
they basically have a choice they can
either mess with canon or they can stick
to it
and maybe that limits their creativity
now i know
that leonard nimoy actually said just be
a star trek fan don't worry too much
about canon and i agree with him to a
point i don't think we have to be purist
about this it's a tv show at the end of
the day
but
at the same time there is a history to
the show and we are geeks we love star
trek for a reason we love the detail i
don't want that detail to be messed with
too much that is a real risk with this
tv show because
i don't quite know the point of it
i understood the point of star trek
enterprise the idea was i think over the
seven years if they'd have got that far
that we were going to see the beginnings
of the federation
the federation already exists for
stranger worlds
we've already seen through the original
series a lot of the exploration of the
of the space around earth
and then in tng we've seen that even
more
so where are they actually going to go
that's different what are we actually
going to see that's interesting in this
series what is the point of the series
i'm not quite sure they've taken so much
inspiration from that original unaired
pilot of star trek
that i i love to think that they have
really do have a plan for this series so
let's look forward to new star trek as
we always do and it should be out
hopefully around the may june 2022
if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification it really helps us out and
please go on facebook there is a link in
the description we have our own group
and i would love you guys to post any
ideas you've got for new videos any
memes you come across they're always
brilliant i post all new trailers on
there and all sorts of things like that
and um
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you